Okay, people.
Today we're going to be looking at SCP-407.
Object Class: Neutralized
Special Containment Procedures:
At time of acquisition, SCP-407 was recorded within a compact cassette tape.
Currently, SCP-407 is backed-up as a digital audio file on [DATA EXPUNGED].
SCP-407 should not be allowed to play under any circumstances outside testing conditions
and only with the approval of O5-██.
Testing of SCP-407 is to be done in completely sound-proof environments.
All tools and subjects must be sterilized to remove the presence of pollen, fungal spores, plant seeds,
and as much bacterial life to the greatest degree possible to delay the negative effects of SCP-407.
Description:
SCP-407 is a song in an unidentified language, seemingly sung a cappella.
The voices are thought to be human.
The tape containing SCP-407 was found with one track of approximately thirty (30) minutes duration,
though the abrupt ending suggests there may be more.
The song has been described by all listeners as something along the lines of 'soothing', 'glorious', and 'beautiful'.
While SCP-407 is played, rapid cell generation seems to occur within an auditory radius.
This effect seems to occur at the cellular level, and does not require the subject to be able to hear the music.
The changes seem to only affect multi-cellular organisms at first,
but quickly begins to affect mitosis in single-celled organisms.
During the first minute of exposure, all multi-cellular life forms seem to become healthier.
Subjects suffering from malnutrition, scarring, physical injury, or chronic diseases
or other medical conditions seem to become healthy with only a minute of exposure to SCP-407.
This has been shown to cure Alzheimer's disease, Crohn's disease, brain and spinal cord injuries,
and normally fatal infections or wounds, amongst other things.
Interestingly, cancer does not seem to be affected,
though the subject's physical condition was still vastly improved.
During the second and third minute of exposure, subjects start experiencing
unnecessary unrestrained cell growth, manifesting in quickly advancing dermal growths.
These growths seem to mostly be benign tumors and calcium and fat deposits,
which though sometimes painful and disfiguring, are not life threatening.
During the fourth minute of exposure, increased bacterial and fungal growth occurs,
creating conditions that grow increasingly dangerous for all exposed life, even in their new healthier states.
Respiratory and digestive problems are quick to arrive in most cases,
and become steadily worse as time progresses.
Past five (5) minutes, the effects of SCP-407 seem to differ each trial.
In all cases, trace elements of plants or fungus as well as any animal life present
begin to grow and replicate uncontrollably, at varying rates, often shaping into new organisms.
Full results have varied depending on the test,
and on the objects present when SCP-407 is played.
This is Addendum-407-01:
SCP-407 was found in the home of Professor ██████ of ██████████,
who had recently returned from research in the Amazon regions of northern Brazil.
Agents were first alerted to a possible SCP when [DATA EXPUNGED]
This is Addendum 407-02:
The mold that eventually resulted from SCP-407's second test
seems to be some sort of Cordyceps Fungi.
Noted to be similar to mold encountered by SCP-507.
Due to fear of fulfilling a fate similar to that observed by 507,
testing using SCP-407 has been limited to using only the first twenty (20) minutes of the recording.
And this is Addendum 407-03:
This is a sample test run of SCP-407.
For full research and experimentation notes, see Experiment Log 407.
Sample Test Notes:
Test 2; SCP-407 played for 28m 32s.
Within chamber; 1 D-Class personnel, unsterilized.
Twenty five seconds.
Subject reports feeling soothed by the music, and of feeling stronger and more invigorated.
Forty five seconds.
Liver spots and scars previously seen are shown to disappear.
Two minutes, twenty.
Subject appears to have physically grown an inch. Increase in musculature is noticeable.
Three minutes, forty.
Subject reports intestinal pain.
Four minutes, twenty.
Subject begins vomiting.
From vomit, plants are seen growing and slowly rooting into the tile floor.
Four minutes, fifty.
Subject starts developing rashes and growths on skin.
Five minutes, thirty.
Heavy dermal disfigurement.
Subject panting heavily, begging for help.
Great pain reported.
Six minutes, ten.
Subject falls to the ground and ceases to move.
Six minutes, forty five.
Subject's body is quickly covered in what is thought to be fungal infections.
Plant growth is observed growing from the subject's mouth, then eye sockets.
Seven minutes, thirty.
Subject is by this time unrecognizable, covered in molds and plant shoots.
Body bursts as a banana tree emerges from the subject's intestines
and proceeds to grow to maturity within seconds.
Eight minutes, forty five.
Plant and fungal growth has begun to spread throughout the testing chamber.
What appears to be moss and weeds cover the floor.
Nine minutes, thirty.
Several shoots, stalks, bushes, and even small trees have appeared.
Banana tree is no longer recognizable;
the tree has grown thick and is covered with foliage and fungal growth.
Ten minutes, thirty.
The air is heavy with pollen and spores.
Vision into testing chamber is difficult.
Eleven minutes, thirty.
Movement is heard within the chamber.
Several different small insect-like creatures are observed.
Creatures are seemingly made of plant matter.
Seventeen minutes, thirty.
For the last six minutes, creatures made of plant matter have been observed to rapidly regenerate,
grow to maturity, kill and eat other creatures, and then be eaten themselves.
Creatures increasingly progressing in size as time increases.
Nineteen minutes.
Medium sized mammalian creatures are observed;
they seem humanoid and bear a resemblance to initial Subject.
Twenty one minutes.
Large fungal stalk is observed to grow from one of the mammalian creatures.
Stalk end bursts, dispensing white spores.
Twenty two minutes.
Plant growth is still lush, but everything begins to become coated by a layer of mold.
The plant creatures seem to die slowly for an unknown reason, before being covered by the mold.
Twenty three minutes.
Mammalian creatures are the last to succumb;
then heavily decay and become covered in the same mold.
Bodies are shown to contract and expand as if breathing.
Stalks quickly rise from the bodies, burst with spores, and then just as quickly rot.
Twenty eight minutes, thirty two.
Tape ends.
No change in chamber since the appearance of the mold.
Chamber undergoes rigorous anti-biological cleansing.
Samples of the mold were taken.
End test.
This is Addendum 407-04.
SCP-407 has been deleted from the system
by what is now known to the Foundation as the Interest Group: Serpent's Hand.
All known backup copies of SCP-407 have also been deleted.
Refer to Incident Report X23.
This is Security Breach Incident X23.
On ██/.██/██, SCP Site 19 breached by operatives from an organization
known to the Foundation only as ‘The Serpent’s Hand’.
Site-19 Breach:
The breach of Site-19 seems to have been the second of two break ins into SCP properties by ██████████,
known to the foundation as “L.S.”
This individual was responsible for a previous security breach, having coordinated the theft of SCP-268.
Though [DATA EXPUNGED], it is evident from video surveillance
that SCP-268 was involved in this infiltration.
The intruder known as L.S. seems to have simply walked into Site-19.
The intrusion seems to have been for the purpose of using SCP-914.
Knowledge of the intruder’s use of SCP-914 can only be assumed
due to the intruders interruption of Dr. ██████ during routine testing.
Dr. ██████ seems to have been [DATA EXPUNGED],
resulting in the intrusion’s only personnel casualty.
SCP-407 seems to have been deleted from the Foundation's system during this time,
so it can only be assumed the individuals involved are responsible.
Whether this means the file has been completely destroyed,
or possibly in the hands of this rogue group, is unknown.
A short printed note was found in SCP-914's chamber;
this note is the only insight the Foundation currently has of the group responsible for this incident.
See Document X23-01.
Dear Sirs of the Foundation
Behind guns and protocol you hide;
desperately chaining the ineffable,
yourselves stuck within your own self-wrought pitiful cages of fear and ignorance.
You think yourselves the shepherd guarding the flocks of the unwise o'er the night,
but you are so shaken by doubt and fear than in your bewildered arrogance,
you would vainly seek to chain the sun itself unto the heavens to hold back the daily night.
The delivering angels themselves you contain with three digits and four walls.
Do you not see the blindness with which you walk and swing your blade?
On the final day, would you have us contain Black Surtr himself with measures and science,
and condemn ourselves to rotten stagnancy as you hold back his pure cleansing fires?
I do not ask you not to act, but act with enlightenment and heart;
neither should one be seduced by the dark nor blinded by the light,
but walk firmly in the twilight and gaze unto all realms.
Walk the World of Fire with bare feet and you will find yourself without the scars you never knew you had.
I leave you with one final truth;
The Garden is the Serpent's place;
the divinities of fear and order who come to walk in the cool evening air are only visitors.
Do not fail to see the evil hiding in the light,
nor the aromatic beauty of the palest flower of darkness.
Signed Sincerely,
L.S.
P.S. - You’ll thank me for deleting what you call ‘407’
This was SCP-407.
Ending transmission.